thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
all right
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
It's the final showdown for a spot into
the season and Final in Toronto a
scintillating lineup and we kick off
with the iconic rivalry as one more time
Magnus Carlton takes on Hikaru Nakamura
and I'm going to put our in-house brand
Masters on the spot Simon what are your
predictions has to be Magnus the best
player of all time he's going to take
him down I'm just I'm going to disagree
I think it's Hikaru nakamura's time six
times features Champion more twitch
followers than Magnus and he always does
it for the fans it's his chance I
thought you were magnus's friend as well
what is this why are you going for it
guys it is the bees to us as the final
boss welcome to the AI cup
oh my goodness that's a move for you
right there I think this is the craziest
position I think we've seen on the tour
this season
oh my god
[Music]
oh he's enjoying himself a bit too much
here isn't he a reaction Magnus
oh no Magnus Mouse left
[Applause]
so good he's so good at thinking on the
flight it's over Magnus Carlsen he takes
it after an exciting final match here
we're ready I'm so excited to welcome
you back from our studio in Oslo with
just one seat remaining at the Toronto
finals it is going to be a fiery week of
testing to make sure that you're on top
of every single move in the studio
Grandmaster David Howell
and ginger DM Simon Williams Simon what
are you most excited about this week
um well it has to be Hikaru and Magnus I
mean two of the greatest players of all
time two of the greatest players of the
moment and they're they're facing off
against each other so we've got to be
really excited about that match up and
who's going to win I mean the
predictions will come a bit later right
but they came a bit earlier actually I
mean how can he say how can he go for
Hikaru over his good buddy Magnus
Carlson you feeling all right Dave they
take it in turns they seem to be beat
each other every time so uh Magnus got
the last one I think Hikaru might have
Revenge list
but David you've been calling the action
from the start and now we're just one
spot left for Toronto what do you think
about the season so far yeah it's been
fantastic Tanya just uh firstly in terms
of the quality of Chess we've been lucky
enough to witness some of the best
players in the world really throwing
stuff at each other and uh it feels like
it has been building up to this point
we're near the end of the season this is
the final regular event and I think
these uh really Stellar casts they're
gonna save their best now for the end
the season-long tour aims at
establishing the ultimate king of online
speed chess and seven players have
punched their ticket to the Grand Final
Magnus Carlson hikarnakamura not back up
to start off with tournament wins
Fabiano caruana Wesley saw Dennis
slazovic and Ali Reza farouza getting
enough tour points to make it to Toronto
they are uncatchable on the tour
standings one name remains to be stamped
in that graphic and these are the eight
players who will be fighting it out in
the AI cup Magnus Carlsen Ali Reza
Dennis and Jana pamushi making it
through with their Julius bear
generation cup performance meanwhile
Maxim washer LaGrange
Anish giri and Hikaru on that spot
through the plains David you called out
the action in the planes looking at the
form of the players who do you think
comes in with the best shot for that
final seat yeah I think we need to take
a look at the overall standings because
because there's still so much to play
for you mentioned four names who are
banging form there Tanya who qualified
for this event but it's actually outside
those top seven uh highlighted in Gold
there that I am looking I'm looking at
eighth place level on aronian who didn't
actually make it to the AI Cup who won't
be playing he's going to be watching
nervously uh from home Vladimir fedexv
in ninth place he's in division two only
uh division one Victory I think it might
come down to that to decide the last
spot in the finals and then we got those
players there as well you got nepo uh
you've got mamajarov they must win uh
this event to get a place in the final
it's the only way uh they're gonna get
through and that means it's double
pressure double excitement and nepo it's
his first time here so he can qualify in
this one event and there that would be a
fantastic for him to do so
so much on the line for these players it
is the final showdown and as um fans
might say that the path to Toronto is
complicated and narrow enough for just
one player to get through and before we
get on the Journey of the AI cop to see
who makes it through let's take a look
at the road so far
under one minute now for Hikaru and wow
what a move and Magnus has had no
struggles against a car over the board
he should be happy we have a winner
Magnus Carlson takes it he wins the air
things Monsters the very first event
he's training
tonight
[Music]
is the winner of the chessable Masters
Fabiano Carona resigns what an
Armageddon game by Hikaru
eliminated
that's it if we have a winner not the
back of the central wins the chess kid
duck what a match performance this has
been by the world number one
checkmates Wesley saw and wins the aim
chess rappers and that is it
unbelievable
unbelievable just here black queen on
the out is going to win this game Magnus
he's got it he's got it in the end wow
what a fight though that was
Magnus Carlson he takes it this is the
winner of the
and it all starts in just a few moments
with so much at stake and on the line
for these eight players uh Simon highly
contested battles very close matchups
here which one stands out to you what
I'm actually gonna say the nepo vs giri
match is going to be very exciting
because let's remember these players
they have to win the event to get to
Toronto so there's double pressure on
that match but uh
um of course I I think all eyes are
going to be on uh Magnus versus his CaRu
I mean they must be right surely that
one is going to be hard to ignore it's
going to be uh hard to take our eyes off
that match between Magnus and Hikaru but
they have both stamped their spot in the
tour finals in Toronto so we'll be
aiming to keep everyone up to date with
all of the action
pretty sure they're sick of the sight of
each other but uh yeah there's always a
storyline there's always revenge on the
cards and I mean so much pride at stake
between those two Warriors those two
Giants this year alone the two greats
have played in a three epic battles in
the finals with gloves on and neither
backing down
now the black king is the one that is
doomed Checkmate is coming Black's King
all alone and Hikaru does eventually
throw in the towel and Magnus has had no
struggles against your car over the
board he should be happy
we have a winner Magnus Carlson takes it
he wins the air things Monsters the very
first event he has to rush this like
he's never rushed before
yep 10 seconds here comes the April oh
match
it's a tight Notch hey car should play
for a win look at the clock should and
he knows it and he does it the car going
it away there was a blunder we'd be six
yeah this part is promoting he allowed
the queen in the party you see it on
magnus's face he knows that does it it's
how they Kara Nakamura defended his
bullet just championship title Queen
takes G3 oh
oh my gosh there's a queen oh
oh my goodness that is beautiful rookie
two he missed it oh my goodness work
things being six again Rook takes P6 and
it's over
here
my goodness he still has something thank
you
both Rooks are sacrificed oh my gosh I'm
on Hikaru it's amazed mate and it's a
draw by agreement and it's the match he
offers a draw a gentleman's draw you
cannot script this any better
I was a finish for the history book so
punches have been traded starting with
the atings Masters final in February
where Magnus won against Hikaru Hikaru
did not have to wait too long for his
revenge in the bullet Chess Championship
winning the finals and then just less
than 72 hours ago Magnus Carlsen won the
speed Chess Championship final rivalries
are not built overnight and these two
have a long storyline so much history
between them and we always have these
iconic sporting famed rivalries right
you've got Muhammad Ali Joe Frazier
you've got Ronaldo Messi I'm thinking
Lawrence Trent Magnus Carlson that was
one as well somewhere on my list but do
you think Simon Magnus Hikaru will go
down as one of the greatest sporting
rivalries I think it has to I mean
Magnus is uh quite possibly the greatest
chess player of all time
um but uh Hikaru now he's got this
massive following he's dominating online
chess he's a great bullet player maybe
the best online Bullet player he proved
that recently so these two players then
they're so close their matches are so
exciting they always come down to one
point so uh yeah like Kasparov karpov in
the 80s and uh I think we've got another
one now we got it you know we've got
Magnus vs zagara and that's what we want
we want these rivalries yeah what's so
fascinating as well about this rivalry
is that there have been so many
different phases they're both in their
Prime now but it started a long time ago
back in uh 2010 they had this famous uh
Blitz match against each other in a
hotel room uh just an informal match
here I believe it was 40 games and uh
Magnus he then had the upper hand
psychologically against Hikaru he was
beating him pretty much every single
time in classical chess but that
eventually turned around yeah
and Magnus won this best of 40 match and
Hikaru went on all well documented that
he actually regretted playing it from a
psychological mindset because it seemed
to give Magnus a big Advantage where he
went on to dominate their encounters for
years to come until 20 SEC 2016. what
happened David 2016 Hikaru finally after
years of trying got his first classical
win against Magnus over the board and
suddenly the mental block it was gone
and uh in recent years we've had the age
of online chess Hikaru we know it's the
king of online chess and he's really
been able to land blows on Magnus and
now they're fighting from a level
footing Simon said it's so close now
between the two it is yeah I mean that
that was maybe a turning point I mean I
think everyone's had that a bad opponent
that he'd lose to on a regular basis but
you need to break that and when Hikaru
broke that by winning that one game he's
got a bit of momentum on his side and
his confidence has grown and probably
his bank balance has helped out a little
bit as well you know you don't need to
worry so much so you can just enjoy what
you love playing chess and uh this is a
proper rivalry and there we're going to
see more of it today which is great yeah
and that next phase as you mentioned
happened during the pandemic when that
pressure came off Hikaru and we're
seeing them fight it out battle it out
on level ground whenever these two meet
we can expect a lot of fireworks and a
lot of fun now while Magnus have punched
their ticket to Toronto the two times
World Championship challenge
it is go big or go home for him he needs
that tournament weekly to make it
alongside his rival who he does play
against today Anish giri a big one for
these two David who is your pick oh this
is fascinating because as you mentioned
Tanya both players need to win the
tournament to guarantee that spot in the
finals I'm going to say despite being a
slight Underdog on paper uh lower rated
on chess.com anishkiri and suffering in
the head-to-head I think this might be
his moment he was really impressive in
the play and just uh recently
keep up his uh form that will be the big
question and we also have another juicy
matchup as we see a battle of speed
chess Specialists here Simon what can we
expect when the French number one takes
on the French number two this is going
to be a great match I mean just because
of the style of player the two players I
mean they both love attacking they both
love tactics and they are you know
they're tactical Geniuses I mean I would
have to say farooja probably has the
edge because he's the younger player
he's maybe a little bit sharper I mean
we all lose our minds a little bit as we
get older is that right I don't know but
a little bit so he has to be the
favorite but it's just going to be good
chess I think that one very exciting to
watch you say the younger player we've
all got to be feeling like fossils
thinking that alireza fuja is not the
youngest player in the archive it is the
16 year old Dennis last week and he will
be taking on a chakra our mama jar of
David what do you predict in this battle
of Youth versus experience yeah a
generational Clash here uh Dennis
lazovic might only be 16 but he did so
well uh throughout this season on the
champions store he's got this really
nice kind of smooth positional strategic
style great at maneuvering greater end
games but he meets his exact opposite
the contrasting style mamajarov is just
fire on the board attacking aggressive
Jason uh yeah I can't wait to see uh
what occurs when those two meet so it's
is it fair to say David that it's going
to be a lot about who gets that kind of
position in this matchup I think that's
the key whoever gets their style imposes
their will on the opponent is going to
win that one
big matters all around but of course the
monkey fight will be between Magnus
Carlsen and Hikaru Nakamura in less than
a minute we will have the first moves
and this is their head to head the
storyline the iconic rivalry does
continue today at the AI cup uh David
they played against each other in that
epic Clash on Friday in the SCC final
what kind of adjustments are you
expecting from the two players coming
into the match today yeah first of all
it's a different time control it's a
longer time limit here today so some
adjustments there but it's all about
those mind games they battled it out on
a various in various different openings
there the Royal appears the Spanish
opening was their main Battleground and
it's just about who spent the weekend
studying harder who can get uh maybe a
new opening on the board and who can
launch the first surprise nice shirt
there
he's got I mean he's got a fair few
bright shirts doesn't he I mean we saw
the pineapple one and I was wondering
what it is with the pineapples and ikaru
someone has to enlighten me with that um
but he seems to love pineapples
we're not looking very ready for his uh
mat against Magnus so third of a Revenge
storyline but Magnus isn't present right
now I mean look at the difference in the
two rooms and you have to say Hikaru had
everything so well organized and it
looks like Magnus like moved in about
five minutes ago there I mean he's got
his quite couch bed there a couple of
chairs I mean what's happening a lot is
happening in that room and my first
question what's that book under the sofa
but Magnus coming back in uh it seems
like he didn't manage to get a change
before this match David yeah I believe
that book is about kind of Soviet chess
history if I'm uh not mistaken
Magnus he's read too many chess books so
it's not enough space in the apartment
for all of them uh but he's here he's
ready to go and uh so are we I can't
wait for this game to kick off
and we'll see how much respect they have
each other in terms of the openings
Magnus normally plays E4 against Hikaru
and Simon we saw a lot of E4 in their
SCC final many Royal Lopez battles from
both these players uh are you expecting
a similar storyline in the openings or
some switch-ups I think there'd be some
subtle changes but I I as David says I
think they're going to treat each other
a lot of respect uh Magnus is known to
experiment sometimes 186 okay we have a
bit of a different move here uh the
Knight hops out maybe suggesting a ready
opening or something similar and uh this
is already a little unusual from Magnus
yeah a really flexible Choice here for a
Magnus depending on how Nakamura reacts
which porn uh black pushers here Magnus
has a variety of different setups to
choose from and okay copy catch us uh he
just uh develops his Knight as well and
Magnus here he hints that he might go
for the English opening but yeah we
could see this transpose into Queen's
gambits we could see it transposed into
Queens Indians all sorts of different uh
positions possible here okay he pushes
the ball getting ready to fianchetto
Black slight Square Bishop that Bishop
is going to land on B7 on a nice long
diagonal and yeah it feels like they're
just freestyling at this point they're
just of course a well-known position but
they're just going through those mind
games that we alluded to they're just
trying to kind of get each other out of
book as early as possible
yeah B6 the move that Hikaru just played
is a little bit of an unusual move I
mean uh Magnus now deciding what kind of
setup he wants to play uh he can either
play in the center or maybe he can find
Chateau on the king side as well and I
mean one of magnus's real strengths and
probably what he's got as an advantage
over everyone else in the world is just
his knowledge of various uh setups I
mean these guys they pretty much know
everything but Magnus like knows
everything in a little bit more you know
you mentioned he had that Soviet chess
book he's he's so well read and research
so uh um and here he goes he's just
assign him to fin Chateau his Bishop
there and um I always think generally
the the fan Chateau Bishop on the king
side defended by the king is stronger
than the one of the queen cykes it's
undefended so to my eyes this this seems
very sensible but normal position a
normal position AKG start from these two
players just feeling the opening rhythm
out right now we did see Hikaru in the
speed test Championship also employed
the system with the black pieces uh this
is going to be a tense fight but the
other fights are on as well as Anish
Curry and yeah
are ready to make
their first moves and we will get an
update on that but in this one very
often we don't see the Queen's Indian as
the choice by some of these top players
a very solid line does this surprise you
David to see Hikaru employ the Queen's
Indian time and time again
some surprise value but uh as you said
that keyword Tanya it's solid and I
think with black in a first game uh it's
best of four here I think Hikaru would
be happy with a solid start a nice draw
uh take the white pieces next and then
start to push that tends to be good
classical chess wisdom um early days of
course but uh yeah it goes through
fashion uh stages and this opening and
Hikaru he's had some success with it so
here we go stay in the Beth Harmon a bit
there isn't he you know uh old Hikaru
and it's always fascinating uh to see
the body language of the different
players and and well he's either doing
the Beth Harmon or he's crying and
Magnus isn't just enjoying a kebab or
something you know he's just tuck him
into his into his probably his breakfast
no Magnus
um at the moment but uh yeah uh okay and
we have we have another game about to
start him
yeah two players looking very solemn
compared to Hikaru and Magnus uh both
players they know this is crunch time
this is where they really need to shine
uh the stage doesn't get much bigger
than this where they have to win uh the
event pretty much to guarantee their
spot in the finals the punish she's
starting with white
he's armed with World Championship
preparation that might be the difference
here he's been so good especially with
the white pieces in the last few years
yeah foreign
it is all about getting that tournament
a victory or a really good finish to get
enough door points to surpass some of
the other players but for that they also
need other results to go that way so the
easiest spot for these two to Toronto
would be to get the AI Cup Tournament
which really they start against each
other
Ayanna promise you with a fantastic
performance in division two of the
Julius bear generation cup meanwhile
anishkiri with an equally incredible
performance in the planes that was
really impressive yeah really impressive
to qualify for this event Anish giri
anyone who qualifies for the play uh
from the planes to the Champions chess
tour is in really top form but he did
ride his luck he did uh actually have a
losing position against her to say of
that giri and he made it through by the
skin of his teeth just wondering if that
was actually a design on their post
t-shirt or if he built his coffee I
wasn't really sure but I think it is
fine just so yeah just so we clarify
that but uh yeah
and there we see a niche as well
preparing preparing and thinking hard
well as the two players set up and get
ready to make their first moves let's
jump back to our Marquee matchup uh some
developments here and white and Magnus
still jumping on his food but also the
Santa he's managed to gain control over
the center has some more space and it
started with a solid Queen's Indian but
has transformed into a pretty Dynamic
Bond structure where black has got a
majority on the queen side but white
more space in the center and a potential
kingside attack yeah this Pawn structure
that you're kind of referencing here
Tanya it more often arises from the
grinfeld defense or from the semi-tarash
defense but yeah here it looks like both
sides have reason to be happy black long
term doing very well as you mentioned
that Queensland porn majority
dynamically white in the current
position uh should be pretty optimistic
because that beautiful Pawn Center and
this is still a relatively well-known
position so I'm slightly surprised that
uh both sides have been burning a bit of
time up to this moment but yeah I think
the game will be decided on uh who can
kind of manipulate this position best
who can get their pieces active quicker
I'm expecting magnets now to continue
development why it's dark Square Bishop
needs to choose a square and later on
it's about whether white can step
forward in the center if he can
successfully he has a big Advantage if
he can't then black should be quite
content yeah we've seen this kind of
structure before quite a lot as you
mentioned and uh I think it's something
up great there David Black's chances
generally tend to get better as the game
goes on right into the ending because he
can get the outside past pawn and uh
Magnus just developing his last piece
there I always like how white in these
positions are I mean you've got a lot of
pieces on the board you've got the I
mean it's white who kind of decides the
pace of the game because uh White has
both of these pawns that he can push at
the right moment you don't have to do it
straight away you can improve your
pieces first but uh it's nice to kind of
be in charge I feel sometimes uh while
black just has to wait for one of those
pushes and try to improve his pieces
take over the open C file
I agree with you Simon and uh I think
for white it's all about trying to get
that player on the king side the Bishop
from B2 can often become a sniper once
you get a Central Pawn moving the move
D5 always in the air to open up that
diagonal start targeting a Black's King
on the queen side meanwhile for Hikaru
the plans are often advancing the queen
side pawns also bringing the Rook to the
Open Sea line and the Knight jumps from
A5 to C4 targeting that dark Squad
Bishop but the big question in my mind
David is right now and you know Magnus
well so I'm gonna ask you
Magnus just woken up do you what's going
on here
um it is past 6 p.m in Norway six
o'clock in the evening uh but I I do
know that Magnus likes to wake up late
depending on the day depending on what
his responsibilities are Magnus is of
course well known he's on record saying
he wakes up he times his uh kind of
sleep patterns according to when he
needs to peek in the day and he'll need
to peek within these next few hours so
hopefully he's been awake for a while by
now but uh yeah certainly not playing so
quickly at the moment not looking his
freshest sharpest uh we'll see when the
game really livens up whether he's ready
to strike I think his priorities at the
moment seem to be his food rather than
the chess you know so he's getting his
energy in uh to to fuel himself there
and we see his last move very logical
move bringing the Rook to the open file
that's where the Rooks belong and here
Hikaru trying to make some exchanges and
as we mentioned before exchanges
generally help hikaru's position you
take the sting out of whites pawns white
really wants to use those pawns to
create an attack I'd say against black
skin there so good good solid moves from
both players so far
all right this one uh is a strategic
battle right now but as soon as one of
those Central pawns start moving it can
become a very spicy on the king side we
will keep an eye out on this one we're
also getting moves on the Yana pamushi
versus Anish Guri matchup a very
important fight in our door standings
for that final spot into Toronto and
this one Acadia start yeah kgs start and
uh We've jumped into the middle game
here both sides have developed uh
castled this did stem from a Sicilian
Defense and white having this moroxy
bind White having pawns on e4 and C4
means that white had the extra space but
now Gary has broken out he sacrificed a
pawn we just saw a pawn capture there on
B5 and black needs compensation Suddenly
It's become really really tactical all
sorts of tricks in the air and both
players calculating the publishing has
barely used any time so he looks
confident what do we think of this
sacrifice uh yeah I guess maybe black
side there is to recapture in the center
of the board with his Knight I think be
the first move you'd want to play and
the idea is to to distract the White
Queen away from the defense of the
Knight and they say Central pawns are
more important than pawns on the wing
but if you look at White's pawns they do
look very scary as they're connected and
if they get motoring up the board they
could cause a lot of damage there but
it's this is this is quite an
interesting position and uh
um quite quite hard to assess really but
Anish playing all the right things this
break he does he played B5 on the queen
side is is the move that you must know
in order to play these positions
successfully with black you need to
break out at some point otherwise your
position is is just too passive and yeah
um it kind of looks alright for a niche
but the evaluation bar is still favoring
white at this moment in time yeah that
gives us a big clue that potentially
White's Queen side pawns will be more
dangerous and there we go at least
easier to push than black Central pawns
uh the fact that Napoleon she's been
playing so quickly up to this point
makes me slightly concerned and if I'm
Anish giri but still a lot to play for
if you can hold up White's pawns on the
queen side the advantage the momentum
could change just instantly so uh key
moments in the next few moves
yeah I said kg and immediately with that
B5 break uh the position becomes very
spicy give white one more move the apron
will advance to A4 hitting that Rook
which now has been stopped by a niche
placing his own Rook on it and I think
it's time to start get the Central Pawn
pawns are moving rolling and we see him
come forward with the tempo against
White Queen are we expecting uh well
black has to defend the C6 Knight before
you can start pushing the E Pawn Yeah
you have to defend the Black Knight or
move the Black Knight he jumps into the
center but I do really fear for Anish
Gary look how quickly Napoleon she's
playing he throws another Pawn forward
these white pawns have already got a
head start on their rivals in the center
there the points are going to keep
rolling down the board and also this is
move 21 I think the Punisher is still in
opening preparation I think he's studied
this position before or at least knows
what to do maybe up until this very
moment and that's a scary proposition
World Championship preparation we've
talked about it before he's prepared for
two World Championship matches and uh he
knows what to do in pretty much all
these openings yeah and he's just
pushing is pulling forward so I mean I
love these plans when I'm playing
because you know I'm not a very
sophisticated player you know I even see
my opponents King and I try to check
mate or I I see a pawn becoming a queen
and I try to push the pawn and that it's
so easy for white to play this position
I mean white can just support those
pawns push those pawns so there's a lot
of problems actually for Anisha because
uh how does he get counter play
um his Central pawns are very slow there
and he's only got one pass Pawn while uh
nepo has two pass pawns and I agree with
David this must be preparation uh the
the speed he's playing the opening kind
of led into this position and we often
see a niche being the better prepared
player but everyone gets tricked out um
on occasions and I just feel that a
niche has has probably been tricked here
in this game and and is struggling at
the moment it's always so hard to tell
how much of it is preparation because he
plays fast and quickly no matter what
the position is he does he plays at the
same tempo right it must be really scary
playing him because you don't know if
he's prepared this or he's just playing
you know and very comfortably yeah he's
uh he reminds me Gary Kasparov you know
very confident player very uh you can
see his emotions on his face he's he's
quite easy to read as well but I think
this is preparation right must be I
think up until the last couple of moves
yeah knew exactly what to do and uh that
kind of comparison with Kasparov is
funny because uh when I first met Yan
when we were really young uh I played a
tournament in Russia and Gary Kasparov
actually was a guest at that event and
he said yeah he's the new me basically
he said this guy is uh the key of the
Next Generation and
you know his position just looks so easy
to play Black is retreated but I think
here white can continue in various ways
maybe the most simple right now if we
jump in and I'm expecting Jan to play
very quickly would be to shuffle The
Rook into the corner
um the plan is to just push these pawns
forward using Brute Force you want to
kick away the blockadas and by moving
your Rook to A1 here you simply uh kind
of set up this big threat if black
chooses to block to continue then I
think you can just trade off and this
black Rook will be passive forever and
uh White can start combining it uh with
Queen moves The Rook is coming into the
nice Outpost it's one-way traffic these
black Rooks are terrible and they're
passive blockadas White's Rooks will
support the pawns rolling forward I I
expect this from Jan Napoli but uh okay
he just plays it uh as I mentioned and
whoops sorry that's me clicking on a
different game this is the position and
Yan has the advantage as white he is
going for the Simple Plan of get the
pawns rolling and we also see the eval
bar gets rolling towards a white
position here for Anish I think he also
needs to do the same in the center of
the board get that epon up and try and
create some chances uh and some
distractions with E5 D4 coming in we
will keep an eye out on this one but
we've got moves in the other match up as
well let's head over to the all French
class between alireza ferrusha against
Maxim vashir lagrav we were expecting
fireworks and looking at the position I
think we should be rather pleased with
this opening
another Sicilian Defense but this time
the open Sicilian often that means
opposite side castling uh kind of mutual
attacks a bit of a race who gets to the
opposition King first and Black's King
uncastled in the center can white break
through in the middle of the board
that's one question the other question
is white king is it safe on the queen
side uh it looks like Black's ready to
launch a pawn storm on that side of the
board and okay all the nights are off
meaning that jumping into outposts those
kind of holes they're less relevant
purely Bishops left Simon who do you
prefer
I'm I I was like having a bit of extra
space and uh in these kind of positions
is King safety is like the most
important thing at the moment white has
the slightly safer King maybe he's going
to try to exchange Bishops off now but I
was also thinking just chess wise this
match is going to be the most
interesting because of their style of
play they both love attacking chess and
uh okay things are now calming down a
little bit with black managing to get
his King over to the right hand side and
the position maybe it's still in theory
it's taken on a slightly different
nature with white trying to control the
center but black creating some uh slight
nuisance on the queen side I mean I
think I still like white here but it's
uh it seems pretty under balanced at the
moment yeah it's just heavy pieces on
the board just queens and Rooks major
pieces here and uh it's all about Mutual
attacks I would hesitate to allow any
lines to open up near the white king uh
if I were for Russia so I'm expecting
him to block it bypass Black's Pawn push
wait spawn to A4 here uh there we go and
the onus is definitely on black right
Simon black needs to compensate for the
fact that White's Rook is Rock Solid in
the center uh White Queen nicely
centralized
it looks nice I mean the valuation bar
thinks the position is is even but uh
the problem is uh White's pieces are
dominating the board right uh you've got
the the last Rook can come into the
center the White Queen can actually come
into the queen side I love this move
from Maxine he's trying to create some
kind of holes around White's King and uh
if White NOW continues to keep the
position closed by moving his C Pawn
forwards you've always got some problems
with your king your king is always in a
bit of a tomb there uh with the white
side so it's uh it's it's maybe uh maybe
enough enough play for black later on
um when if he can if the black queen
ever gets into White's position then
black will certainly be better yeah
white needs to keep control maybe the
queen comes in uh using this Square for
example after a trade of Rooks uh
Black's Queen suddenly has a path in and
if it ever gets behind as you say Simon
there's going to be some nasty
checkmates so uh watch out for that rear
guard action here white needs to be
really careful and I'm expecting first
you need to trade off a set of Rooks
White's Rook is just two powerful
um so you have really in the balance of
kind of visually white looks uh Superior
here but counter chances for Bachelor of
later on and it all is because of that
B3 Pawn just really cramping while it's
a king they're creating chances of the
Checkmate that you were pointing out
making sure that white can't get too
active in this position a dynamically
balanced one let's head back to uh the
Magnus Hikaru game as uh alireza
Ponders as Maxine Marshall McGrath
Ponders his next move in this one and
there we have it wow that's a lot that's
happened the d-pawn was pushed to the
center of the board captured and instead
of recapturing Magnus first decides to
jump in with the Knight coming in with
the tempo hitting the queen also opening
up his own Bishop so that he's able to
recapture on D5
it looks really Pleasant for white right
now we talk about fee and cats with
Bishops and white Bishops on G2 B2
they'll just control the whole board
shortly and also momentum white he's the
one creating the threats
suddenly body language expert Simon
Williams thank you David so looking at
the body language of the two players I
can barely see Magnus because it's a bit
dark in his room but uh we I mean he he
looks pretty chilled out he's probably
digesting his food and uh Hikaru this I
mean he's got a very unique thinking
pose isn't he I mean he uh he always is
the Beth Harmon thing where to recall
his information he's always like looking
around the room and just trying to uh
calculate away from the board
um it's interesting as well I mean I
think in this the other day the way
chess has developed so Hikaru has kind
of coined the king of online chess and
there's a big difference now between
playing online and playing over the
board I mean playing online you kind of
recall everything in in 2D uh so you you
know and playing over a real board you
recall everything in a 3D way and I I
think some people just you know memorize
and get can get to that information uh
in an easier way if it's 2D or 3D he's
definitely a 2d guy
um and it's it's weird how uh the the
brain thinks when you're trying to uh
calculate these lines but
um white must be doing well here I mean
this move it attacks the queen a Magnus
can simply go Pawn takes Pawn which he
has done and that pawn is very dangerous
and as you say look at White's Bishops
so Hikaru playing very bravely here and
uh just aiming to uh get some
compensation by exchanging the queens of
wow we have loads of moves I mean you
know what's going on you know it's about
10 moves happen there so uh that that
was remarkable how quickly they played I
mean it's not bullet chess anymore guys
just just chill just chill a little bit
it's not the ICC but David you need to
do an action replay because so much
happened and just so quickly yeah so
quickly and we saw uh if we backtrack to
this moment uh we jumped in here the
White Knight has just leapt into the
center attacking Black's Queen Hikaru
paused like Simon said he was looking
around the room uh he spent two or three
minutes and then suddenly we saw the
flurry of moves both players calculating
and it's instructive for everyone at
home Magnus calculating on his
opponent's time that's something to bear
in mind you want to save time in any
Speed game Quint A4 a very forcing move
attacking a pawn white recaptures again
forcing type remove checks captures and
threats Queen takes born another capture
the queen slides across to defend her
Bishop watch out there's some nasty
checkmating ideas if the white knight
jumps out the way the White Queen can
take on G7 uh so Black Blocks this
diagonal but then the black queen is
almost trapped only one safe Square
forcing a queen trade and white regains
the pawn that was captured on the a file
earlier so after black snack Retreats
this is the uh kind of remnants of that
kind of melee that we found ourselves in
and white still has this really strong
past Pawn only three squares away from
promotion the question is is it a
strength or a weakness uh black watch
out for this Pawn long term has the
outside Runner further away from the
Kings so if all the pieces disappear
then black maybe uh for Choice it's
really still hanging in the balance but
the lack of Queens means it's now more
about really concrete play Magnus
playing four here defending his Knight
and uh yeah I think I would still choose
white but
I think maybe some of the advantages
gone I think Hikaru really practical
decision to trade off those Queens
yeah maybe it just depends how dangerous
White's Pawn is in in the center of the
board and uh at some point White's just
going to try to jam that forwards right
and uh if if Hikaru can neutralize that
pawn then he's going to be absolutely
fine there's nothing else to worry about
uh but there's going to be many tactical
points here because all the Bishops are
lined up against each other as well so
you've got to keep an eye out for any
any exchanges so any night moves any
poor moves to unleash those Bishops so
Hikaru needs to use his time now and uh
he's having a good think about how to uh
neutralize this position maybe moving
The Rook into the center makes a lot of
sense uh move it in front of the pawn
this would be the the first move I I
think you'd think of but I don't know
maybe there's some tactics there if that
happens and it's just got to be a little
bit careful if he's a little bit careful
uh he should be all right here yeah
another thing to calculate for example
the move I want to play as a rook to A8
and uh before we decide whether to even
trade Rooks Magnus has the option of
taking this bishop we see the evaluation
bar drop it doesn't work but this is the
type of thing that hikara is calculating
the pawn could now step forward and uh
there's a nasty skewer on this night on
this Rook it looks like the pawn is uh
about to promote but black does have the
Saving Grace of moving this Rook out the
way with a counter threat uh Rook to A2
and this is not maybe an easy move to
spot you're leaving your night hanging
but uh tactics in the air this would
work out for black and I think if you
can get the Rooks off the board he
should so I'm expecting Rook A8 from
Hikaru after a bit of calculation
how even though the Queens are off the
board the game the position has so much
to play for and so many tricks to watch
out for in this one because of the deep
on and of course these two fighting it
out till the end when you're playing
against Magnus you have to make sure
that you're aware of everything even if
the position is balanced we did hear
from Magnus on
Twitter right before his encounter
against Hikaru Nakamura and let's see if
we can bring that up well Magnus might
not have been might not have had a
Shabba before this match or changed his
clothes or had his food but he did tweet
that revenge is a dish that's not served
at all so he's talking about the SEC
final where he won against Hikaru and uh
he's saying no Revenge today for you
yeah I mean this rivalry that you know
they they take it really seriously they
they both laugh at the end of it yeah
but really I mean they're you know
hikara is dying inside when he lost that
one as Magnus was when he when he lost
the one minute so uh they're kind of one
one big event each so this is uh this
this is important to them you know they
want to they want to show who the the
boss is of online chess yeah I think
every time they play against each other
they're just able to bring out the best
uh in each other to fight it out uh and
uh while they have a think in this end
game while Hikaru tries to neutralize
all of magnus's edge in this one let's
uh head over to Jana bonusi versus Anish
Gary as we see the eval bars slide more
and more in favor of Yan's Queen Side
Pawn Star which he's gotten all the way
to A4 and B5 meanwhile for a niche those
Central pawns still stuck still haven't
managed to create the their counter
chances but is it as easy as uh what the
eval bar seems to imply here I don't
think it's as easy for humans here to
convert White's Advantage but look at
the clock times uh 10 minutes 45 against
under one minute already for anishikiri
he was caught out in the opening uh I
think we've uh kind of discussed that
before that's settled now but somehow
surviving this this middle game I was
gonna say end game
um yeah that is a tough order with no
time on the clock and look at what
Nippon is she's doing he's saying you
have one plan Black's only plan is to
push the Central Pawn he's blockading
that and then he's got a free turn he's
got a free hand to push his own pawns
straight forward for why it's so easy
and quick to play and oh the evaluation
bar reacts even more uh very natural
move there from Gary what could the
refutation be
yeah I mean this this is a move you
expect black to play but he does leave
his seventh rank quite weak and uh I
suppose the first movie you have to
calculate here is the the white Rook uh
just moving forwards one square uh
attacking Black's Queen but also
attacking the weak point on F7 trying to
get the queen uh into the into that
square
um but I suppose black is defending here
I mean I we've I don't know if you can
go Rook C8 but that looks a bit strange
or maybe just Queen E8 there uh so
that'd be The Logical movement and the
other idea is just keep pushing those
pawns right at the right time I mean
there's a couple of options but uh Rook
C8 could be the move there but E5 it
looks very human and when you've got
under a minute on the clocks kind of
move you're gonna play uh without
thinking too much yeah this position now
on the board time and look suddenly the
evaluation bar has dropped Jan rushing
the position uh he had so much time on
the clock here if he had followed your
second ID assignment if he had pushed
the pawn forward based on a nice
tactical trick I think uh White is
simply winning on the spot uh after he
thought I was gonna say maybe you can
even take this Pawn and then throw your
Pawn back down to B7 but even if you
just Retreat uh the problem is black
spawns are not rolling any further if
you ever step forward here uh this Pawn
drops and I think he would have won but
let's catch up with the game instead
Queens are off the board suddenly and
whoa where's the advantage gone let's do
a quick action replay uh we saw Rook dc8
a nice counter threat a pin the Queen's
disappeared and suddenly white going for
the F7 Pawn F5 a big blunder oh a
blunder but why
it must be to do with white pushing this
Pawn does he do it now or does he first
bring his Rook across
all based on this B Pawn and wow look
the computer here the engine suggestions
below the screen below the board they do
confirm that Rook to B3 only winning
move on the board and he plays it yeah
Simple Plan
and I think David the point is that if
you would have pushed the beep on first
black simply lines up his Rook against
the beep on B6 you've got Rook B4 but
after the move that Yana Palmer she has
played the beep on is Unstoppable now
yeah the B Pawn is now Unstoppable and
uh okay we see a few more moves black
did take this pawn and he's trying to
blockade desperately but uh White is
simply going to push this Pawn forward
bring his Rook across and get rid of
this blockader Black's Rook is not going
to hold the fort for too much longer
yeah this game's going to be over soon
and uh the problem here uh was anisha's
time as well well his position and his
time maybe he could have held uh that
with a little bit more uh emphasis on
the clock but he he didn't manage to do
that and uh buried the B Pawn is running
through the board Niche trying to hold
on as long as he can but now that Rook
can even come to A8 or just maneuver to
the seventh rank uh it looks very tricky
and he's giving up his most important
Pawn there and yeah it's it's not easy
this is a killer move isn't it just
trying to get a rook to the last Rank
and get the pawn to become a queen so
nepo's gonna get this one yeah white is
simply going to play a rook to d8 check
get rid of that blockader make a new
Queen it will cost black as rook and
Black's d-pawn looks far advanced
it won't get much further however
White's rook and White's King are near
enough to stop that pawn running this
one is game over
it is uh game over and Anish Gary there
has resigned 13 seconds on the clock for
10 minutes for Jana Pony he takes their
first game in the matchup in a
convincing manner with that Advantage
out of the opening converting it so
honestly the other games are still on
let's head back to Magnus let's start
with this one alireza against the maxim
washer lagrav we did check in with this
position one pair of Rooks were traded
but white has managed to recapture with
the pawn which actually ties down now
Maxim's pieces to defend it from
advancing further yeah this has real
shades of the previous game actually
that we saw between the publishing Geary
in that it's just major Pieces Just
queens and Rooks and it's all about past
pawns white spawn looks super strong so
why does the evaluation bar say level
um Simon I'm confused here I would take
white all day long yeah it looks really
good for whites I mean if white can open
up some more lines here then um Black's
position is is going to crumble but I
guess there's always chances to to to
get around the back and get into White's
position I mean black has a threat right
you want to go F6 next yeah and kick the
White Queen and actually win that D6
spawn yeah so maybe F5 here would be
would be a normal move to play
yeah maybe we can show this uh F6 is a
huge threat as Tanya points out for
example if white is just one move too
slow F6 the White Queen can no longer
defend her pawn and uh here suddenly not
just his black and pawn up but you will
be maybe breaking through to the first
rank to deliver a killer check
um so F5 is the uh key move if played
what is Black's reply if you take this
Pawn now it feels like you're going in
the wrong direction at the very least uh
White can offer a trade of Queens get
rid of that blockader just like we saw
in the previous uh game the previous
example uh so F5 looks super strong he
hasn't played it what else is he just
calculating the consequences here
I think this uh is pretty much an
automatic move to play especially in a
rapid game uh you have no other options
no other option I'm just wondering is
the other break-in option here F5 very
tempting is alireza also considering the
move G5
maybe that's the one maybe uh this is
what's tempting him right now and after
a trade of Pawns I'm not sure maybe I
guess you take back at least for now uh
the F6 square is under lock and key
white still has this nice formation and
Simon it might be time next for your
Acorn yeah I'm amazed the evaluation bar
does does not uh approve so much White's
position because it looks like white is
doing really well here I mean the black
queen it can't move because it allows
White's d-pawn to push on the black Rook
looks uh very passive so uh why why is
it saying that black is actually okay
when white has this lovely Queen this
lovely Pawn in the middle of the board
it's uh it's uh not clear to me maybe
the Black Brook slides back and some
chance of a counter attack suddenly a
blitz attack against the white king this
is the direction we're heading in uh
White has just played G5 so we'll see
how the game unfolds I'm now expecting
Black's Rook to move there's simply
nothing else you can do
the pawns are frozen blacks Queen it's a
blockader but she is threatening to come
out take A4 go for the white king
Stakes are really really high on this
one and you can see it's a kind of a
local Derby Battle of the Frenchman but
they both want to win it look how
focused they are yeah this was an
excellent move Rook CA and she pointed
out yeah really good way to get counter
to play really nice idea and if White
Queen was to step back to defend that
Airborne from the square of f4 or
anywhere on the fourth rank black can
actually push that c Pawn to C4 again
renewing the threat that David was
talking about Queen E4 or queen F4 would
I think David run into C4 and you're
again wanting to pick up the A4 pawn and
create uh your own threats against the
white gang yeah I think we'll see you'll
move on the board at any moment now
Tanya and uh is it interesting at all
that Maxine vaseligraph is wearing a
French national top in this battle of
the Frenchman
yeah I mean gotta be Patriot you know so
and uh um I'm now actually like in Black
it's funny how how one little tactical
move can can change the position around
and uh I suppose white has counter play
on the king side maybe you can also push
his G Pawn so it's getting to a very
critical and uh exciting moment in this
match here
um but yeah interesting position uh that
we see and if black does play this moose
C4 I'm assuming white can play on the
other side of the board and push the G
pawn and that that will lead to a lot of
chaos and we're gonna see C4 and there's
a big fret The Black Queen threatening
to take the pawn and come in and harass
White's King there and you've got
actually defending it for A4 Bond you
have to find your counter chances on the
king side yeah it's one of those cases
uh defense is overrated here it's just
impossible uh you just have to fight
fire with fire and go for the black king
and it's a bit of a gamble remember the
players don't see the evaluation bar so
they have no idea whether they're
winning losing here both players have
reason to be optimistic but
um also counter play in the air it's uh
yeah real doubt in both players Minds
for sure G6 has to be played Simon I
think go for it on the board G6 this is
fire on the board and we're getting a
big update that there has been big
developments in the Magnus Carlson
Hikaru Nakamura game as the players are
under 20 seconds with an end game where
Magnus Carlsen once again has done some
Magnus magic Magnus magic is always in
the end game that Magnus is able to
weave his net trick his opponents and we
talk about the power of the two Bishops
it's level pawns here but the only
imbalances that white has the bishop
pair and look suddenly trading off and
he's going for that remaining born on H7
and that's it
we have a result
wow Hikaru results
yeah you can see his body language there
as well I mean uh white White's just
going to take the pull on the right hand
side and queen is H Pawn there's there's
nothing that the Knight can do to to
stop that so uh yeah first Blood to
Magnus Magnus uh not letting that
Revenge dish being served Hikaru
immediately leaves of course the battle
continues it is a best of four and the
battle continues in this one as well we
left it when alireza did strike with G6
Maxime does take it back you can't allow
the capture on that F7 pawn and now
because the E6 is a weakness Maxim
doesn't have that time to capture on A4
yeah both sides are a bit stuck white
doesn't really want to touch anything uh
White's Queen if it does go and capture
some pawns uh I think okay maybe uh now
it does allow a potential offer of a
queen trade
um yeah black is really really stuck
right now so not too much to do he
either has to move the black Rook to
support to bring it over as a defender
of his king or he has to evaluate what
happens if the Queens come off the board
Queen F7 being one tempting option okay
he keeps everything combined here and
it's got a little trick uh David a nice
little trap there yeah we have to show
this Tanya took me a second sir I think
I would have missed it I would have
played a move like H4 and whoops Queen
takes Pawn would be a killer deflection
tactic
and uh nasty background Checkmate we've
talked about it a long long time ago
this white king is actually really
vulnerable due to the presence of this
Pawn cutting off his Escape squares so
watch out for those background tricks
over the next few moves how to guard
against this big question and you've got
to be tactically so aware against Maxim
and he does guard against it because he
chops the queen back to actually over
defend the D1 Square so now the trick of
Queen D6 doesn't work you capture the
queen and after a check on F1 because of
that last move Queen to G4 The Rook does
drop back to D1 yep covering everything
really clever play there from both sides
and watch that it's also threatening to
take this Pawn
how is the evaluation bus still in the
center here it's such a chaotic position
uh for black the stakes are really high
maybe the key question is whether you're
going to take this Pawn now and just go
all in go for the white king but it does
come at the cost of this Pawn with a
check
Edition with Queen H3 and queen E6 I
think so it seems like kind of a
perfectly played game uh pretty much I
mean uh White seems have control but um
mvl has found some great resources and
uh here we go they're repeating
positions because Black's got a major
threat of the black queen coming in with
a check and then demolishing uh White's
pawns on the queen side so I think they
have to take a draw and just a very high
quality game yeah I wonder what the
accuracy levels are for this game for me
it might be 99 for both
just no mistakes at all canceling each
other out neutralizing each other and
this game does end in a three-fold
repetition we have the result third time
we've seen this position and uh very
very fair draw there to start the day
yeah really quite a big fight there but
we and Maxime and alireza ends in a draw
with nothing better with white to do
than to repeat with checks with that big
threat for maxim some fantastic
defensive and attacking resources in
this one and we've got Maxine vashiella
Graf with black finding his counter
chances in the kind of positions that he
enjoys playing and the battle does
continue against
his teammate alireza Fairuza for now no
teammates it's full rivalry on the board
four big games four big fights David a
lot of big moments there which one was
your highlight I'm gonna choose the
moment uh just to show everyone what
happened uh but Magnus Carlson turned it
on against uh Hikaru Nakamura and won
that really close end game here White
having the two Bishops as we saw being
the decisive Factor later but Hikaru
came up with the wrong plan he retreated
his Bishop to f8 we'll see what happened
there but it was a faulty idea he should
have brought his Knight to D5 going
after this Pawn instead the Black Knight
black Bishop are gonna gang up win this
pawn and most likely this game would
have fizzled out to a draw instead
retreating his Bishop was not the right
path Magnus played a really clever move
Bishop to D3 if Bishop takes Pawn now
his Knight will be overwhelmed and we
saw how this game ended Hikaru had
nothing better than to repeat Retreat uh
lose two moves and suddenly this white
Bishop came round and as we saw Hikaru
resigned in this position about to lose
a key H Pawn white about to make a new
Queen
the Magna starts in the end games and
this is what we were talking about that
even if the position is level it's just
never over when you're playing against
the world number one and it is a game
one down in the books with Magnus taking
his lead against Hikaru yeah
with a convincing dominating first round
Victory against Anish giri alireza Maxim
quite a battle which ended peacefully
and Dennis against chakra we didn't get
a chance to look at that one but it was
a level battle a peaceful one that ended
in a draw between these two and of
course the chess action continues on
chess.com join us for twitchcon in
wiggas from October 20th to 22nd mark
your calendars that is 20th to 22nd
October we are hosting an official
Chaska Booth where you can play chess
win prizes and meet some of your
favorite chess creators we are so
excited to be taking part in the
festivities and can't wait to see you
all there use the command wig is in chat
for all the details we will see you in
Las Vegas that is for later right now it
is all about game two action as some of
the players are playing a catch-up in
their match Hikaru Anish need to win a
game to level their matches we will be
back with game two action in just a few
moments
foreign
[Music]
defense to the untrained eye this is a
performance enhancer you don't see it
how about now manage your air quality
sharpen your performance change the game
with air things
we're also excited to announce that this
tournament that just.com is partnering
with browser maker Opera we are thrilled
about this collaboration and something
for chess lovers everywhere it truly
puts the game right at your fingertips
no matter where you are and we did ask
some of our players a lot of fun
questions are with the Opera AI take a
look
so first of all thank you for taking the
time to do an interview with chess.com
but I have to tell you we actually
already did the interview with you using
Oprah's AI engine Arya we asked it to
answer questions asked Anish giri and
are you ready to be confronted with your
answers
yes yes definitely all right so first
question was who is your biggest
inspiration and you answered my biggest
inspiration has to be the legendary
chess player Gary Kasparov
wow so far so good yeah yeah I think I
would have said the same actually what
is your favorite time control my
favorite time control is classical time
control I think uh it's the one that had
the best results in uh probably by
probably by faraldo hard to say if I
think of my style I would expect myself
to be
strong and Rapid but somehow the results
uh
yeah the results don't don't show the
same I guess it's because yeah I've been
sort of focusing on classical for just
much much too long what is your favorite
opening and the answer was if I were to
choose a favorite it would be the real
Lopez
I I think the AI wasn't fed enough of my
tweets where I'm constantly promoting my
neither of course and then we ask who is
your biggest rival and the answer was
players like magnet Carlson Fabiano
cariana and Vladimir kramnik have been
formidable opponents and have
consistently challenged me in
tournaments and matches
wow
I mean it's a decent answer because I've
played with these players a lot of games
um so yeah good good answer there but a
little too too generic I think what is
your ultimate goal in chess My ultimate
goal in chess is to become the world
chess champion
yeah uh again uh generic but in this
case it works very well I think that's
the
you know uh for me I think that's the
ultimate goal have you reached your Peak
as a chess player the answer was I
believe there is still room for further
growth and Improvement in my chest
career would you agree
I'm sort of improving as a chess player
for sure
um but it's extremely challenging how
would you describe your personality so
I'll sum up it says compost
analytical ambitious diligent respectful
and Sportsman's life and with a sense of
humor
yeah I mean the I hope the respectful
and sports ones like was not
the sign of of the humor
but very very
uh which is also
also also a fitting because I'm not
modest and I didn't mention modesty what
is your IQ
and the answer and I hope you can give
us the correct answer the answer was I
don't have a specific IQ score to share
with you but I remember I once had an
online test that I wanted to to do I
don't know why like probably some kind
of spam came and like some maybe like a
10 minute IQ test it's very very nice so
or 15 or so anyway very short size
decided to complete it and it went
pretty smooth and I got I think like 139
yeah wow and it said like um so it said
you know okay you are this good great
you know smart all that and it showed
that if you are above 140 you are genius
and I have 139 I think okay
hang on a second let me do one more
because I just want to cross the 140
right I mean that's all like who doesn't
want to cross these things yeah so um I
did one more 136 came out I didn't want
138 cameras I didn't want more 133 137
came out 139 I kept doing them it was
already late I couldn't cross the 140.
whatever I do whatever I do I just
cannot be a genius
what is the best thing about being you a
niche and it answered one of the best
things about being me is the opportunity
to pursue my passion for chess at the
highest level chess is not just the game
for me it's a way of life
oh very very very cool very cool
very nice I I'm a little surprised it
limits the answer to chess only you know
I would probably give a more General
answer as well you know I'm family
myself now and all the friendships and
you know this blah blah I would mention
for sure do you know who hacked your
Twitter account
and let's see if it gives an answer no
it says well it's quite an unfortunate
incident that my Twitter account was
hacked as of now I don't have specific
information about the individuals
responsible for the hack yeah that is
true I did the this uh police report
back then and um I guess they treated it
as like just like another bike theft
yeah so it means nothing nothing came
from that awesome thank you for
answering Anish you just got Aid
the Opera AI seems to know Anish giri
pretty well and you can download the
first ever World Chess themed browser
powered by Opera it's on go.chess.com
Opera it's a really cool one with a
chesscom widget and a lot of uh fun
extensions on that and David Howell is
supposed to be right here on the studio
panel with his expert commentary but
while we were on break he decided to
have some fun on the Opera browser
that's right everyone no I'm not
slacking off work although I sometimes
do I'm actually checking out the Opera
browser and I'm really in the mood to
play bullet I've been watching these
great sir these world-class players play
so let's check out as I take you through
a bullet game using that Opera browser
this is uh my screen right now I'm gonna
open it up here we go pretty cool pretty
slick uh chess.com opens up from the
slide so you can hide this easily if
you're playing chess at work I'm going
to go in play a game I'm going to set up
a bullet game let's try and win quickly
okay I'm gonna play one minute chess no
time for more I'm gonna also put it
unrated so that uh I don't lose any
rating points here and who wants to play
me someone please play me I just
realized I'm gonna change the change the
settings here to make it uh against
anyone so if anyone's online on
chess.com this is your opportunity
you can also play puzzles of course here
you can do anything you want and wow
I've been put on the spot and nobody's
playing me it's my is okay here we've
jumped in I'm gonna pre-move I'm gonna
pre-move the whole game and
as you can see this is a pretty cool
service Simon what do you make of my
moves
yeah I like it reverse London system uh
it's got to be a good way to go and uh
yeah pretty solid seems like you're
doing all right
I'm uh okay I'm just gonna play some
dodgy moves here to try and open it up
uh so we can finish before Magnus and
Nakamura take over with their better
chess but uh right now I'm liking my
position I'm just gonna get my king to
safety this opponent's really strong
it's really frustrating I thought I'd
win this one nice and cool to show off
are you feeling the pressure David I
actually am
super nervous right now
um okay all my pieces at the party
centralized I'm Gonna Keep pre-moving
and I'm gonna start going for checkmate
oh I think this this guy's just too good
he's gonna make me grind him down into
some end game wow in 40 seconds for both
of you 40 seconds
wait is it even my move I'm gonna
pre-move I'm just gonna keep Brew moving
if he takes my queen so be it
wow and the action does continue with
David's bullet game he's still playing I
can see that happen while these two are
also ready to start their second game
David we're gonna need you back here
really soon
Magnus has started with the Queen spawn
opening he does lead a one to zero
winning that first game against Hikaru
wow and Knight C3 on the second move are
we heading into a potential jubama
London here I think we are yeah I mean
this is the start of the Jabbar of
London
um and this move is uh it's becoming
more theoretical uh as we're going on uh
in time and uh David you've played this
as well and David you're back what
happened to that bullet game you got to
tell us so I offered my opponent a draw
because I wanted to rush back to the
desk my opponent rejected my draw offer
the cheek of it so I had to resign ah
there chest comes first these guys come
first was it rated it was not unrated
okay that's good and Simon it's your
system you've produced uh courses on
this one you need to talk us through it
uh to the dropover London system on the
board it is yeah and uh Black's played
the most critical move here uh C5 which
is very logical because the White Knight
is on a bad square and um now white has
two main choices so you can move the
pawn in front of your king one square or
the more aggressive uh two squares up
the board was actually an idea that Hans
Neiman I think first came up with so it
is going to be interesting to see what
is played here but generally the
evaluation is positioned if black plays
correctly it should be even and C5 is a
very good way to meet the Jabar of
London this is the more aggressive move
and um just trying to remember I think
it's Knight takes Pawn now or Pawn takes
Pawn are both pretty decent moves Pawn
takes E4 uh ways to equalize this is the
the known equalizer uh theoretically and
uh it just shows that uh yeah I mean
Magnus knows everything right so he's
going to know this line
yeah Magnus has played this himself with
white as well so he's clearly found a
way uh to try and dampen things
trade-off pieces what is the correct up
his sleeve
Juan is pretty hot from the very start
with the opening approach that these two
have we will jump back to this but we're
also getting moves in the Jana punishi
Anish giri matchup Anish needs to switch
it up from what happened in game one he
needs to forget about that he starts
with the white pieces uh starts with the
Queen's Pawn what are you expecting
David will he try and we're seeing a
similar opening I was gonna say will he
try to score that victory in this one
with white or is it about stop the
bleeding I think it's uh firstly about
stop the bleeding you never want to lose
a game with white that would pretty much
signal uh I think the end of the match
it's hard to recover psychologically
from two games defeat but no jabova
London it's just a pure London system
this time and
um yeah I think Anish giri this isn't
part of his usual repertoire so uh he's
definitely got something up his sleeve
and we see the evaluation bar react
already can white just snap off a Pawn
on the C5 Square
um what has the problem she got up his
sleeve remember the last or one of the
most recent uh games he's played against
the London system ended in defeat in his
world championship match against ding
yeah and he's trying to maybe uh remind
him of those traumatic moments Mind
Games Mind Games already yeah I mean
this again Must Be Theory uh that this
this queen move
um uh something that nepo must have
prepared because his whole setups become
very popular and supposed to be a way to
equalize with the black pieces against
against the London system so but Pawn
takes Pawn that's critical because if
you play Pawn takes Pawn here it The
Black Queen recaptures then the White
Queen can dive in to the position is it
some kind of sacrifice that Jan is
trying to set up this would be in his
style especially against someone like a
niece you want to try to get the
initiative against the nation and try to
uh keep it keep it as tactical as you
can so that that could be his idea but
Anish thinking having a big think here
and if you haven't studied this Pawn
takes porn already you might be a little
bit unsure whether you should play it or
not and maybe you'll play a safer option
instead
all right well this one a lot more of
this saying start a more strategic
London in this position that we've got
the other game that did end level in
round one but was full of fireworks
Maxim Russia now starts with the white
pieces against the alireza feruja both
extremely aggressive Dynamic players uh
expecting
Maxime in this one to start with the
King spawn I think so yeah I'm hoping
for another exciting Sicilian but okay
um Ali Reyes has gone for a much more
solid setup uh the the petrol fear and
maybe he learned his lesson from the
last Champions Tour event where he tried
the Sicilian against Magnus and it
really backfired and I think this is a
wise approach from Ali Razer trying to
go for a more solid setup here yeah and
uh remember these guys know each other
extremely well from the French national
team I think they've had training camps
and they know each other's openings
preferences clearly Knight F6 uh the
petrol defense has got Maxine
vashilograph thinking uh maybe not
feeling comfortable definitely a shock
because foruga rarely employs this
opening then again vashil degrav is one
of the leading experts in one E4 he also
won a beautiful game against the Petrov
in the planes for this tournament uh so
definitely kind of reasons for both
sides to pause it's a bit of a surprise
here we see a very symmetrical setup uh
look at the kind of symmetry in the
position or the night staring off
against each other we will most likely
see some trades and I think vashilograph
reacting to this surprise in a very safe
way
yeah yeah it makes sense to play quite a
safe setup and when you have a
symmetrical Pawn structure it all comes
down to the pieces so uh whose pieces
are are more active here and uh White
just trying to get his his bits into the
game offering uh black to double his
pawns which black can do but you'll get
a lot of activity in return for that and
both those Knights and Senate aboard
they look quite scary so we do have a
change of Pawn structure black now has
the better Pawn structure what is
White's idea is he gonna support his
Knight with a pawn maybe uh that that
looks like an interesting way to play
and he's got to try to justify the
doubling of his Pawns in in this
position
the Petrov a solid start level opening
and the other match that's level let's
jump over to chakra momedarov against
the youngest player of uh this season of
the Champions chest or 23 Seasons Dennis
lazovic who won a division two and then
went on to impress us in the division
one of the Julius bear generation cup
he's already made it uh through to
Toronto with these two spectacular
performances and in this one he's going
to be playing against
shock with the black pieces we've been
talking about The Clash of styles
between these two uh what is it going to
be with the white pieces how is shark
going to try to get his kind of
positions
I'm he's got to make it complicated
because Dennis is quite a classical
player even though he's so young yeah he
really understands how to keep it uh
safe and solid uh but mama jarov is an
expert at creating Chaos on the board so
maybe something like the trompofsky some
way to complicate mess it up and uh so
far we're seeing pretty standard stuff
here David yeah pretty standard stuff
the game has transposed into the Queen's
Gambit declined uh black not trading off
anything in the center just rock solid
uh formation nothing too spicy yet but
mamajarov has uh kind of tricks up his
sleeve he often throws pawns forward on
the king side towards the black king in
the early days but no it's a very uh
typical topical
kind of set up here for both players
white taking the space look at how
White's advancing all the pawns on the
queen side now got a nice Pawn structure
uh clamping down but black has no
weaknesses at all and black will start
chipping away at the pawn structure and
wow at the least expected moment Harry
the H Paul makes an appearance yeah this
this is the kind of move I expected from
my major of just to try and uh make it a
more complicated game I mean it's not
the normal move from Willy throws G Pawn
forward now let's hope so he could
really go for major complications with
that move because the last move that
Dennis played has created a bit of a
hook so if white can ever push his Pawn
to to attack that one it'd be great and
uh uh but back to sort of solid solid
play on The Queen side now
yeah and uh here we see the main idea
for black in this opening that Bishop
was terrible Black's light Square Bishop
trapped behind its own Pawn chain he's
just trying to trade off and lessen the
pressure on his position and Matt Majora
says okay no strategic slow grind for
you I'm gonna explode things and this is
a pawn sacrifice throwing the B Pawn
forward he's trying to force black to
capture we're upon the White Sea Pawn
will be a past Pawn uh this game's
getting crazy already first he plays the
Harry the H Pawn on one side of the
board and then we see a standoff on the
queen side if you do pick up the B5 Bond
I think David what you pointed out is
the key moment that white can actually
use that opportunity to advance ahead
with the c Pawn winning a Tempo with C6
before recapturing on B5 the pawn can
land itself on the seventh rank so you
really don't want that which is why
Dennis last week falls back with the
bishop so the tension is still on we see
some trades now on the queen side but
we've got to jump back uh just for a
moment to the Magnus Hikaru game because
it is absolute dude Madness in that one
the Magnus Madness continues uh Hikaru
getting greedy I'm doing the count here
hey Carl has an extra Pawn but look at
that King in the center out in the open
White's King might live to regret this
whole opening black does have the bishop
pair that being said an extra Pawn is an
extra pawn and if white survives the
next few moves Magnus won't be too happy
it was actually a complete role reversal
because after just four moves Magnus was
a clear Pawn up and he chose to give two
pawns back uh to clarify the position
let's do an action replay and this is a
complicated position we'll break it down
but um just back here we left it all the
way after E4 Knight takes E4 and Simon
as far as I know the normal move is
Knight takes Knight here that's right
yeah Knight takes Knight is what white
normally plays so uh what I dare did um
Hikaru show Knight B5 okay I've never
seen that idea before uh it kind of
makes some sense because you try to
force Black's Knight to go to a bad
Square which I assumed it did now the
only way to stop the check but you have
given up a pawn so very interesting idea
uh from Hikaru but how did it work out
yeah white kicked the Black Knight back
the Knight used this Square maybe it
could have gone a direction to be a bit
safer and uh after we saw a set of
Trades we saw this position B4 a really
clever move the black queen checking the
white king hitting the white Bishop so
there's no time to actually go and
capture this Pawn uh the white Bishop
would simply drop back and block what
would be a piece up and uh so we see
this position on the board and Magnus
has just played the move Bishop to E7
he's getting ready to activate these
pieces watch out for this bishop to
maybe use this diagonal a bit later on a
really nice long diagonal the other
Bishop might come this way to hit the
White Queen White really has to catch up
with development I think this White
Knight has to move and White's King
really wants to go to safety but as you
mentioned Simon the fact that there's
this laser vision the white king cut off
from Castle and kingside that might be a
long-term problem
yeah it's the king's safety and the
blacks Bishop should always be quite
good compensation as well in the long
term so uh I'd certainly favor Black's
position interesting opening idea for me
Karu but Magnus has reacted very well I
feel here and White's gonna somehow get
his King to Safety in this position
which is not going to be entirely easy
yeah definitely don't Castle uh Queen
side there's no safety to be found uh on
that flank I think that's the one thing
uh Hikaru most likely won't do unless
he's playing for Content should we do a
vote whose position we prefer because
this one evaluation Bar says 50 50. yeah
well I'm going to go black because I I
was like having the safer King and
Black's King is safer here and you're
sure that has nothing to do with the
fact that Magnus is playing Black Magnus
for every tournament in the door Simon
ah well you know I am a bit of Magnus
fan but I mean it is the Jabar for
London as well so that kind of evens it
out and uh also a new for my eyes and
new opening ideas so I I would have to
uh say that that kind of evens out I
just like Black's position I like to say
for King what about you Tanya
I I'm a fawn Grabber uh I do I do agree
that it does feel a little unsafe for
white with the king and the center also
really no direct path to actually go
shark Castle you can't develop your
knight to E2 but that still doesn't help
you block the diagonal but the king will
be required to defend that Knight on E2
so it doesn't really help the cause but
I still like White's position I don't
really see a way for black to get to
White's King and that last move A4 he is
threatening to go B5 next to block that
diagonal
um I think it is definite compensation
for Magnus but I'll pick white hair
David you're the I'll break the tie yeah
you're the tiebreaker I'll say white
because I picked the color at the
beginning of the show and I don't want
to back down